As the morning sun shines
on the Golden Gate Palace,
brother and sister Hisham and Asma
prepare for the journey of a lifetime.
It is 791 CE, and the Abbasid Caliphate
is at the height of its power,
stretching from India to North Africa.
With over half a million inhabitants,
its capital city of Madinat al-Salaam,
also known as Baghdad,
is the largest in the Islamic Empire,
possibly the world.
And it's only 30 years old.
Asma and Hisham will leave
at sunset for the hajj,
the holy pilgrimage to Mecca.
Most people make the journey
when they’re older and wealthier,
but Hisham and Asma have wanted to make
this journey together
since they were children.
They intend to travel
with the big hajj caravan
that is protected by the caliph soldiers.
The caliph Al-Rashid himself is also
traveling with the caravan this year.
The hajj caravan is like
a massive mobile city,
with soldiers, cooks, doctors and
merchants, servants and enslaved people.
The journey is long, with dangers
like disease, robbery, and dehydration.
Because of these perils, Hisham and Asma
want to travel with the larger group—
but a last-minute mishap threatens
to undo months of careful planning.
When the siblings visit the market to
check on the supplies they’ve purchased,
the merchant tells them
one of their camels has fallen ill,
and he doesn't have any replacements.
Without the camel, the siblings won't
be able to depart with the caravan.
They search the marketplace,
bustling with people from different
ethnic backgrounds,
such as Persians, Arabs, Turks,
Africans, and Indians,
and following different religions
like Islam, Judaism,
Christianity, and Zoroastrianism.
The market sells everything from locally
made pottery, Egyptian glass,
and paper from Samarkand, to Chinese silk,
gold from Africa,
and fox fur from the distant north.
But with the caravan leaving tonight,
no one has a camel available.
Though the hajj is primarily
a religious journey,
the siblings have other,
personal hopes for it.
Hisham and Asma come from a wealthy family
and both had tutors as children.
Hisham is studying to become a scholar,
progressing from Arabic grammar
to Islamic law and Persian love poetry,
then to Indian-inspired mathematics
and Greek philosophy and medicine.
With scholars from all over the empire
traveling to Mecca
and important intellectual centers
on the way,
the hajj is a great learning opportunity.
Asma, meanwhile, has literary ambitions.
As a woman, a life of formal scholarship
is not available to her.
Instead, she is honing
her skills as a poet.
She hopes to compose poetry
about the journey
that will catch the attention
of important women in the city,
and maybe even Queen Zubayda.
The siblings split up to search
for a camel.
Hisham heads toward the library complex
to ask the scholars’ advice.
An elderly scholar studying Galen and
Hippocrates
tells him how to treat a wound.
An Aramaic translator from Damascus
shares a list of useful herbs
for upset stomach on the road.
A Persian poet wants to share
his latest poetry,
but Hisham doesn’t see how that will
get him the camel for tonight,
so he kindly refuses.
As he says goodbye, they give him
the names of important theology scholars
to visit in Medina,
on the way to Mecca.
But to get there,
he’ll need a camel.
Meanwhile, Asma visits
an older, married cousin.
An enslaved girl opens the door,
and takes Asma to the women’s quarters,
where men cannot enter.
Her cousin wants to hear
Asma’s latest poetry,
but Asma tells her she’s in a hurry
and explains their predicament.
She’s in luck— her cousin’s husband
has a camel to offer them.
With their arrangements secure at last,
they make their final preparations.
At the designated times for men and women,
each performs a ritual ablution at one
of Baghdad’s many public bathhouses.
As the sun sets, the city’s criers
announce the caravan’s departure,
and the townspeople flock
to watch the pilgrims leave.